si va a ser sometido a una operación se
le puede administrar anestesia general
para dormirlo y no sentir dolor
el médico le puede recomendar anestesia
general para un procedimiento que es
exhaustivo que dura mucho tiempo o que
requiere que usted esté en una posición
incómoda antes del procedimiento se le
introducirá una vía intravenosa en el
brazo utilizando un pequeño tubo llamado
cánula
la misma le proporcionará líquidos y
medicamentos directamente al flujo
sanguíneo puede recibir medicamento que
lo ayudará a relajarse será colocado en
la mesa de operación de la manera más
cómoda posible se le colocará un
brazalete de presión arterial en el
brazo para controlar las lecturas de la
presión arterial se le colocarán
almohadillas autoadhesivas en el pecho
para controlar la frecuencia cardíaca y
un broche en el dedo para controlar los
niveles de oxígeno de su cuerpo estos
dispositivos permiten que los
especialistas en anestesia controlen de
cerca sus signos vitales antes durante y
después del procedimiento comenzará a
recibir anestesia general mediante la
inhalación de gases anestésicos a través
de una máscara o a través de una
inyección intravenosa que hará que se
quede dormido una vez dormido se le
administrará una mezcla de oxígeno y
gases anestésicos mediante la máscara
o un tubo especial insertado a través de
la boca y de la tráquea
el tubo se adjunta a un respirador que
lo ayudará a respirar mientras los gases
van a los pulmones
en la profundidad de los tejidos
pulmonares los gases son absorbidos en
el flujo sanguíneo y transportados por
células sanguíneas al cerebro la
anestesia evita que el cerebro reciba
mensajes desde los nervios del cuerpo
como consecuencia permanecerá dormido y
sin dolor durante el procedimiento y no
recordara nada del mismo cuando
despierte luego de la operación el
especialista en anestesia le dará
medicamentos para revertir el efecto de
la anestesia y usted se despertará
rápidamente si tuviera colocado un tubo
respiratorio se lo quitarán apenas pueda
respirar de manera segura por cuenta
propia lo llevarán a la sala de
recuperación donde lo controlarán de
cerca y en caso de ser necesario le
administrará un medicamento para el
dolor es posible que se sienta mareado y
un poco desorientado pero esa sensación
pasará rápidamente una vez que esté
estable será enviado a una sala del
hospital oa su casa